so are you totally addicted to candy
crush or what
but you don't have a smartphone oh you
don't have a smartphone what do you mean
you don't have his heart but oh why so
what does your phone do wait what does
it look like does it have a keyboard
can't you text
I'll get it does does it have Internet
do you still a snake on your phone why
don't you have a smart phone is it a
money thing you must want one all right
but you want one right but come on you
you wish you had one right why not right
don't you ever have like moments you're
like mad must be so much easier if had
an iPhone how do you drive anywhere how
do you know where to go you still print
out directions how do you know what to
eat how do you know if a restaurants
gonna be good
what are you doing those little moments
where you're waiting for something or
someone
what are you doing you get bored okay
but like what if you just want to go
somewhere spur-of-the-moment what if
there was like a giant fire or an
earthquake or something I mean how would
you know what to do so what are you do
in the bathroom just sit there don't you
do it stop life it's fun though it's
like it's like you're always in the 90s
I wish I could go back but my phone is
my life you better off without one
you'll spend way too much time on it
you